sounds like
Thomas labor party is quite quite
serious about trying to create a country
where everyone has a chance to grow old
in good health I think we should all
welcome that the big question is can
they do it
um the last time we had a labor
government it did transform the NHS but
the challenge this time it's harder the
starting point is worse and where
they're trying to get to is it's a
higher Peak as a harder climb not only
are they saying we're going to bring
down waiting times across the Health
Service they're saying actually we're
going to improve survival rates and
we're going to increase life expectancy
that's a really tall order it's going to
need investment but I don't think anyone
thinks we're going to see the same kind
of investment that we saw under new
labor that's six percent a year so that
means the labor party if it does form a
government will have to go much further
much faster on finding the right reforms
both within the Health Service and
outside of it if they're going to
deliver on those missions where does the
money need to be invested because of
course everybody everybody would put
their hands up to say yeah we want a
better NHS of course we do but you know
it literally literally is is a
pot of money and whatever money you put
into it you always need more well it we
need smarter use of our money right we
do need these reforms and there's no
point rewiring the circuit if you're not
going to put new batteries in and while
funding funding is a pretty critical
determinant of how good our public
services are but it isn't the only one
so what they labor are saying is like
what we need to do is try and shift how
we spend our money within the health
system so it's not just we're not just
waiting for Illness but we're creating
Health that means putting more money
into primary care and into Community
Care so we can try and stop people
becoming very unwell I think that's the
right idea
um whether whether we see that happen or
not is is a big question but prevention
really is a really important step to try
and bend that cost curve down healthcare
costs will go up but how quickly they go
up that's within our control that
depends on the policy choices we make I
remember my GP telling me more than a
decade ago that social care was the
ticking time bomb that was going to do
for the NHS yeah social care and the NHS
have are dependent nope it's important
to see social care in its own right it's
it's a public service that is very
valuable one that we have ignored and
ignored and ignored we've seen
politicians of all Stripes over promise
and under deliver on social care and it
should be respected in its own right but
it does have a knock-on consequence in
the NHS let's think about hospital beds
and the reason we find it so hard to
create more hospital beds is because of
the pressures and social care so I
certainly would advocate for more money
going to social care I would increase
access to social care so people aren't
paying lots of money out their pocket
having to sell their homes to fund their
own social care but it also completely
transformed the workforce it shouldn't
be the case that in a country like
Britain people I'm leaving the social
care sector because they can get paid
more stacking shelves in a supermarket
that is not okay we need to realign the
the reward of being a care worker to the
amount of the contribution these people
make to our society we're Junior doctors
strike under a labor government well we
we don't know we haven't got a labor
government
um we don't know where the junior
doctors pay rise will go it will depend
very much on what any next government
does with the NHS does it become a
better place to work and what is key to
that sure some of that is about better
rewarding Junior doctors but it's about
passing more power to the front line
people want to have a bigger voice in
their workplace we're seeing where
Street and yesterday talking about
actually let's give patients choice I
think that's right but patients and
people are working stuff they don't just
want choice they want voice that's where
we need to set our information it's
always great to see you Doctor thanks
very much